[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the show we are all laughing
we are laughing for a reason and that is
because today is NBA Tuesday right here
on the bleacher report app with me and
the man that is next to me I call him MB
you might know him as Michael Bolin and
next to him is the man we like to call
producer Ryan here on the show uh guys I
got a question for you we are in
December December 13th uh we're close to
Christmas close to getting there
I got a question are you guys real
Christmas tree guys or uh non-real
Christmas tree guys like talk to me and
you guys in the comments talk to me too
which one which ones are you putting
your bets in on real Christmas trees are
not real Christmas trees I'm going I'm
going fake tree because I don't want the
tree dragon real Pines in the crib but
I'm gonna be very honest with you I live
in a shoe box here in Chicago I don't
have a tree at all there's nothing going
under it you can call me the Grinch if
you like but I'm not wasting my time
money or effort on a Christmas tree I'm
just gonna ride right through the New
Year's yeah I know I'm I'm a fake tree
guy to the core because a real having a
real tree is like just having a big ass
plant in your home that you got to take
care of and I'm not if I were if anyone
ever gave me a plant that plant's dying
within three days so forget about the
tree man now fake tree low maintenance
is Ryan's low maintenance guy but uh hey
let's get let's get right to it guys we
we talked about Christmas Christmas is
in the air hopefully the spirit of
giving is
coming up on us tonight for this NBA
five-leg parlay that we are about to
whip up uh welcome to the show welcome
to the show all the new people that just
joined the show welcome to the news I
mean not the new show but welcome to the
show my name is Greg Ivory next to me is
MB I like to call him MB but you guys
might know him as Michael Bolin and next
to him is the guy we like to call on
this show Pro do sir
Ryan producer Ryan that is his name
did we lose Greg I think we like yeah I
think we lost Greg uh no way
unfortunate it's unfortunate that's you
know he was talking he was talking his
talk before the show it's just called
Bad Karma bowling uh but well while
we're waiting to get him back that was
weird Ryan I heard what you said that
was probably you you probably sent
something to my internet feed and got me
up out of here okay I see how you're
playing today Ryan oh oh it's me it's me
it's not like okay you were talking
before this show started I came back in
here and next thing I know I heard your
voice talking about oh he was talking
before his show started I know okay The
Vibes all right here we go hey it's time
to cook up another five leg NBA
parlay you guys you guys fans people are
in the comments drop your Best Bets for
tonight in the chat Ryan
producer Ryan what are the people
talking about bro yeah so there was some
uh fake tree talk that was uh that was
going on Darion said fake tree ain't
nobody uh ain't nobody got time for that
fade the real tree uh effects but uh so
like we said last week right FanDuel
runs this promo where it's a 25 Free Bet
um if it's the NBA on TNT games so the
NBA on TNT games we have today are the
Warriors and bucks and Celtics and
Lakers uh your team and my team Greg so
uh we're gonna start cooking that up we
have uh flip a sway jumped in and said
Draymond over five and a half assists
I like it
listen I'm I'm an interested party in
that first of all before I get my
commentary together I don't even want to
forget that the milk discussions we had
last week I got my chocolate milk ready
so I'm ready to get this
um listen I was in the lab this morning
and the the six assists I think for for
Draymond is a really interesting bet I
think this game is going to be pretty
high scoring I think he's going to be a
really big part of how the Warriors get
their buckets tonight the only thing
that worries me and Greg you can talk to
me about it I feel like these big games
some reason he always ends up with two
technical fouls so we just never know
and I don't want him to get popped in
this game and ruin our bet
no yeah Dre is known for getting the
attacker too but I think we might be all
right we might be eyeing this situation
bro I I will say too they said five and
a half his line is six and a half so we
could just take the six plus I also
wanted to jump in because we're bringing
up milk again and Darian darian85 jumped
in here said somebody get my boy Mike
some airpods for Christmas and Ryan's
some milk please so I'm nipping this in
the bud right now I brought
some milk this week uh some almond milk
so I gotta shake it up real good and
then we're gonna pour it out and I'll
I'll drink the milk because that's what
the chat wanted so I'll pour it out and
I'll drink some milk I don't like the
way that looked when it came out
this is such an epic moment we have
literally drinking some milk we've
really divorced we forced Ryan to drink
some milk so I don't want to hear it
anymore I drank some milk I got in here
I poured out some almond milk
I'm not a dairy guy I'm not a milk guy
you look like uncomfortable right I'm
incredibly uncomfortable I I don't drink
milk at all
but all right let's get back let's get
back to that let's get it
um six plus is 195. we could do that
um let's see
Blake said get that fake milk out of
here it's
real milk what are you talking about
it's milk
oh my God this is so great look there's
so much milk talk we've got baby you
can't milk that you can't rat says you
can't milk a nut
that's funny oh my God we're not even
going there
um let's see
Giannis over on points I'm assuming his
over under is like 30. yeah that's close
to it let's see I saw somebody dropped
in here uh
for Ren said Giannis over 30.
uh let's see
what is this guys enough with the milk
I'm trying to I'm trying to win right
now uh
it's over under it's 31 and a half so
minus 160 I mean listen Giannis can get
30 in his sleep I feel like as long as
he's making free throws he's going to
get very very close to this number so I
don't have any problem making this the
first leg I think that a lot of people
are going to have plus 30 and a lot of
their parlays maybe that's not a good
thing but it's something I like that you
think I like this no one no one on the
uh the Warriors can Guardians my fan I'm
a warrior fan die hard all right yeah
there we go guys Giannis 30 plus uh
let's see somebody just dropped in here
and I like this because we can go over
to the other game uh Dante kashaw said
Marcus Smart over 11 and a half points
oh right we'll we'll lean on you for
this one you're the Warriors I mean not
the words the Celtics fan yes sir uh uh
very anti-warriors don't don't say that
Greg
um it's about it's a bad slip up on your
end uh I like this one here here's what
I will say and I'm gonna ask for some
thumbs up and thumbs down because I may
want an alteration here
I kind of like Marcus Smart threes
like hold on let's go over here because
it is at 11 and a half I'm correct if
I'm correct yes 11 and a half what
what's his threes at
one and a half
two threes
he definitely shoots a lot of them he
was in he was in a parlay that I used
that I played a couple days ago you're
gonna get the volume I think this is
another game that's probably going to be
pretty high scoring in the end of it
because I think the Lakers won't be able
to guard the Celtics very for very long
so if you go to two threes what's the
value at it or what's the number
two threes would be minus 150 as opposed
to getting it at -158
I also think I like him to go ahead
Sorry God no I just
he's too
he's hit that Mark in two of his last
four games
so
it's it's a gamble it's a gamble it's a
it's a gamble now now he's right would
you feel more would you feel more
comfortable with the point total
I don't know
let's ask the people I want to jump in
here for a second because while we're
here not to completely go away from
Marcus Smart but we got to listen to
everybody in here uh Jay hodderman said
Jalen brown two plus uh three pointers
is a lock same with 20 plus points I'm
gonna ignore the 20 plus points because
we're here minus 300 as a leg is not
horrible we could do we have done a lot
worse
you're getting a lot more of reliability
in terms of the The Vault not the volume
but the percentage shooter here okay uh
the volume matters and I think the
market spark play is not a bad one but I
feel much more comfortable with JB over
two all right uh let's do that and then
and rad jumped in here and said Al is
out tonight y'all don't forget Al
Horford has been out all right I think
the Lakers win Tatum been slumping
offensively I disagree I actually think
I don't think that there is a world in
which the Celtics lose three straight
and I think the fact that we can get
them at minus 166 and then we can start
playing around with the other two legs
like if we want to go back to that other
game I kind of like this
are the did the Celtics play last night
yes they did they lost to the Clippers
I don't know I don't love I don't love
games in a back-to-back
um the Lakers are playing better I don't
think the Lakers are very good at all
this would be the first time we put a
side in one of the games
um or one of the parlays so I'm not
against it
um I will jump into the chat I think the
Marcus Smart thing was a good avoid we
see Darian saying it's a tough one D
trench drench gang saying don't take
smart for nothing
please saying leave Marcus Smart out so
uh I think we're on the right path
moving JB in and I don't know Greg you
think he's going to be able to convince
us to take the Celtics I'm kind of iffy
oh well this isn't Ryan's parlay this
isn't my parlay and B this isn't even
your parlay this is not the people's
parlit uh so we have to ask the people
we asked if Ryan did we oh yeah yeah
thumbs up thumbs down hand up hand up
hand up for me hold up I I I see though
I see in the comments a lot of people
were talking about A.D I see darian85 he
says 80 over on rebounds we need 80 on
the ticket I also see flip dollar 23
Anthony Davis on points don't sleep on
them
okay so if we want to do recall we
almost put a D in the last one and he
got and he got sick within three minutes
of the game no way not saying that's
gonna happen again but
I'm always weary of A.D I think that I
think the rebounds in this game probably
makes more sense than his points
um but I don't know I I'll leave it up
to you guys to which way you guys want
to lean because
uh I don't know what about this one what
I'm what about this one and be my bad my
bad MB but I see Jack Jack cam says
smart four plus assist is a lock
I like Marcus Smart more dishing the
ball than shooting threes and scoring
points I just feel more comfortable you
know what I mean yeah yeah yeah uh I
will say is that it right there yeah
okay yeah minus 13.50 I love my guy
jackham he he's in every one of these
shows and he drops some locks in here
but uh minus 13.50
let's see what that would do let's see
what that would do
uh yeah no no thanks thank you for
dropping well hold on hold on what's
what's this line like let's let's talk
about his assist totals
I was thinking about bringing that up
um it's at six and a half I I also like
Marcus Smart to Dish some out I wouldn't
be against taking six I'll be honest
minus 260 again you know we've been
taking a little bit of chalk here
and it still doesn't get us a plus 200.
um
I don't know I I will say this the chat
keeps dropping Zion and embiid
propaganda
NBA on TNT games NBA and T games we're
just trying to ensure that you guys get
your money back if we lose yes which we
won't but in case we do yeah
so
um
AR-15 yeah I just saw that so what about
AR-15 last time we had him on the ticket
he hit I'm just saying he did he did I
do like that
AR-15 Celtics on the back to back
my man is becoming like a low-key folk
hero there he saw him he was interacting
with some of the girls Courtside he's
coming into his own I kind of like it
I kind of like it what's his player
what's his what's his points at yeah can
we take a look at his ass
eight and a half
points that's it yeah what is it to add
10 in there
how we're talking
I want to know what the Chad thinks is
the chat about Austin Reeves I see some
well bro
I like Lonnie Walker I'm a big Lonnie
Walker I like Lonnie Walker too but but
my guys he had nine points 25 points 10
points I get his last three games my
man's been going over that eight and a
half mark
oh that's why I'm talking about I know
but like you see a guy who scored 25
recently and his point totals at eight
and a half
does that not feel like uh oh you're
actually drinking milk right now bowling
uh does that not feel like bait
right it feels like I'm not being put on
a hook right now Ryan I mean
you are entitled to feel how how you
want to feel oh yeah yes for sure always
yeah but but if you do what you know you
supposed to be the man of the people
looking into the chat I am I was about
to I brought up body Walker
you would see that a lot of people are
talking about AR-15 yes they like they
like they like us bringing up AR-15 and
uh rocking with one of one of one of his
props
Fresh Prince called it the lock of the
year
do you do you feel like your your
strategy of going to check his threes
over the points is a better Play because
I'm saying CLE here Clee 15 saying
awesome Reeves over two three so if
you're worried about the hook we only
need six points
[Laughter]
so hard bro AR-15 I think that's this
one it's easy yeah I think so too eight
and a half so we're not doing the ten
we're doing eight and a half
this is where we start getting in
trouble uh okay no no no no no no
because the this is good the 10 got us
to like plus three whatever this is
still plus 300. let's do this let's do
this okay okay this looks good let's do
it can we go back to the other game
because uh this is It's I'm getting too
much Celtics Lakers I guys I don't want
to be up until midnight watching our
parlay I'll stay up as long as it means
we're winning money I'll stay up all
night
yeah that's why that's why you gotta
come to the West Coast man it's the best
coast you ain't got to stay up all late
watching games you know what I'm saying
you can still watch the games at a
reasonable time and do what you need to
do after the game yeah West Coast Best
Coast uh but anyway we're plus 300 we
got three picks we need two more Ryan
I'm back in the comments because I see a
lot of people a lot of people are in
here
talking about your boy that you just
mentioned Lonnie Walker
but you want to go to the other game
though you want to go to a game I'm just
I'm looking at other comments as well
and I hey I'm gonna
I'll bring this up to you guys because
we have trust issues but this man
particularly Jay McCullough 22 says Klay
Thompson 20 plus points
no I'm not in yeah we have a we have a
list I think I need to start bringing in
a list I'll put it behind me it's called
the banned list and Klay Thompson is
number one on that list
so dying not today not not today yeah
but not today
no way uh
oh Chris Middleton I see that flip
dollar said uh Chris Middleton 15 plus
and clay and he said and Klay Thompson
over points again no
no
I'm not filling the clay but uh Chris
Middleton to go get 15.
uh
who's the who's the
who's the primary Defender for for the
wing is it going to be Clay is Clay
gonna have to check Chris
uh should be Andrew Wiggins should be
okay so pretty decent defense
what uh 15 should be like you know Leia
territory there it is
no that's minus one yeah I was trying to
I was trying to tease it all the way
down to 10 points I'm nervous about this
one his Line's at 16 and a half we're
basically taking it over
yeah I mean I think no not really I mean
with the point and a hook
well I was told last week I was told
last week that we couldn't buy it down a
point because no it was a half Point man
that's a big difference a point and a
half is a big difference I don't think
it's that big of a difference well when
you talk about the money it is I let's
see put it in there for 15 and let's see
what we get at minus 165. it's gonna
jump it's gonna be good
here we go
yeah the Warriors they're not I mean
they play a decent defense but they're
not just like locked down scoops I'm
saying alert and rad wigs out Amy
Wiggins Wiggins is hurt Wiggins out
Wiggins out I like this even more now
I'm not even gonna stop waking this out
two-way wigs is out the people that's
why we need you guys you guys and we're
we're in this together we are all in
this together he they gave us a scoop
Wiggins is out
who's the defender that's going to be
guarding Middleton well if it's Jordan
Poole he's going to have 55 times
barbecue chicken
I like my bad JT but um I don't think so
it's Clay Thompson clay I mean Clay's
eye but you know he's not moving like he
used to
are we not concerned that we basically
took the over for Giannis and Chris
Middleton
oh that's a great point
I'm not necessarily what really worries
me is Fresh Prince says left Chris left
the last game with a sprained ankle no
play on that
right that's a great point
that's a great Point let's let's I think
so pretty consistently what's what's
debatable very debatable
oh hey what's Steph Curry let's let's
look at Steph Curry what's Steph Curry
got going on
um it's 28 and a half
at this rate if we're gonna keep taking
these overs we might as well just take
the game over
risky Reese saying Curry five three five
plus three is he shows up today easy
five three it seems like a lot but it's
Steph Curry greatest shooter of all time
so five of them
wait wait hey hey so look it if the
people is telling us not to trust Chris
Middleton
does that mean we take the under
oh this would be the first time I think
we've taken an under on this show
I mean der Wheezy is funny he said he
don't trust the first feed Chris
the first time for everything uh locals
perm said Giannis double double
can we even put that on here if we can I
do like that
oh no no we can't that was uh not the
same name parlay leg that's on me that's
on me that's all right I didn't know
either no that's we're good uh
yeah risky Reed with the curry five plus
threes that's a lot of Threes that is a
lot of three
four threes
MB oh no that's not Jay Hernandez said
yeah is over 25 if if anything what do
we have in here that's that's jolting
this up
okay
what's Westbrook three uh three point
total Russell Westbrook Russell
Westbrook
Russell West I'm sorry did you say
Russell Westbrook
Brody Westbrook Brody Westbrook threes
is lock of the year
who said that who said that
oh under under oh okay in red two five
seven yeah
okay we'll go yeah all right you gotta
be fired up for a second I thought we
were taking another Westbrook over
he is a bricklayer yeah but he is he
can't shoot threes he's a bricklayer we
took and we took his assist last week
and he didn't pass the ball
yikes
all right let's see what it is
oh my God he can't it's just over one
it's one
so it's like are we gonna uh how are we
feeling about this one
I personally hate taking any oh unders
that if it's just one I I don't know
what it is man
I don't I I remember when hoppy gave us
the under five and a half points for
Patrick Beverly I wish we could have
added that to that first parlay but he
might make one
is Pat Bev on there what's his is I
don't think he's still suspended yeah
hold on let's see what is
this point
uh we could do that is was he on there
hold on we're jumping we're jumping too
much let's see what is Westbrook
actually hit per game from three
let me look I got you
we got K streets saying West Brook
threes over which is not it's a
contradictory because
I
he's he's
Steve you on the year
Steve Stephen up now saying he's rocking
with Westbrook over one three-pointer
she's got to make one
I think he can make one
I feel like he can't too
he shoots him I'll tell you that much
I mean last game he only shot one
yeah you're right but the game before
that he shot five game before that he
shot four and then the two games before
that he shot one I won
I mean he's shooting them this is too
this is too volatile I don't know about
it yeah I don't know about this either
guys I'll be honest
so what do we have in there now it's 30
yeah middle two we have do we have
Draymond in there somebody's saying
Draymond over five and a half rebounds
did we visit that earlier I don't think
we know we visited we talked about this
we can go back uh somebody said Draymond
over on threes they're they they just
want to lose money do we want to we want
real real takes in the chat we need real
takes in the chat do we want to fade
Westbrook's points
it's 13.
no okay all right I don't think so all
right
people are saying don't do don't do
Westbrook avoid anything Western that's
from Fresh Prince all right Fresh Prince
1986.
uh come on go with your gut all right
I see another Marcus Smart over 11 and a
half
are you gonna sell us Ryan are you gonna
sell us or what I like we have too much
from that game
let's see no I mean we're split even
right now we got Austin Reeves we got
Jalen Brown and then we got Marcus Smart
I personally would be more Comfort God I
don't know I'm so I I love Marcus Smart
I think any Marcus Smart play whether
it's assists or points is probably a
good bet I'm just trying to decide which
one's the better one
and then I think how about this well add
Mark is smart in there let's let's do 10
plus let's do 10 plus points and then
look at that yeah all right let's do
this
you're going to have carpal tunnel
before this show is over I already know
we're going back and forth I already do
plus 772. I think we can buy down one of
the uh okay so the so the one buy down
that everyone was talking about was Move
Young Giannis yes 30 to 25. okay I am in
full support of that I'm with we still
got Chris Middleton yeah yeah I'm with
the Chris Middleton take I I like the I
agree with you guys I think Wiggins
being out is gonna help us
definitely
so if this number doesn't go down super
crazy moving this from 30. I kind of
feel like being good too
kind of feel like what if we moved down
Chris Middleton
uh I mean we could write 15 to 10. let's
see what that does
I might not might not be good for us
nope not good for us I'm cool with the
15. I like the 15 I think that was a
real strong take that we got earlier
yeah so now we got some we got some
support Jay Hernandez saying yeah 25
Darien saying 25 is good and rad sang 32
high for show so we're in a good spot
right now
at 568
what do you guys think should we should
we get an opinion
I think now is the time for thumbs up
and thumbs down in the chat let us know
thumbs up you're riding with it thumbs
down you would like us to continue to
change well Ryan well you gotta you
gotta read read it for him read it for
him so they can know what their thumbs
and up and thumbs down to good call out
Greg good stuff Jalen brown two plus
made threes Austin Reeves over eight and
a half points Mark is smart ten plus
points
Giannis 25 plus points and Chris
Middleton 15 plus points
thumbs up thumbs down in the chat and
let's see I kind of like this one and I
like it for a number of reasons I think
we teased down a number for Giannis
Chris Middleton I think we're getting
some pushback because he left the game
with a sprained ankle we're gonna have
to deal with injuries in any way but
the real truth is he can easily get 15
especially with Wiggins out I see no
problem with him getting to his
mid-range and potentially getting to the
line because the guys that are replacing
them do a lot of hacking so kind of like
this one what do you what are you seeing
in the chat right you seeing thumbs up
or something a lot of thumbs up a lot of
thumbs up seeing a lot of thumbs up so I
think we should call it guys like I I if
you look at the chat I see a lot of
thumbs up the people that are putting
thumbs down are people that are trying
to not bet on TNT games
that's very interesting point we told
you guys we're trying to keep this TNT
games tonight they gave us an extra
boost
uh so
trying to keep it TNT games that's why
we're not picking Joel embiid and all
the other guys that are playing tonight
um but I see a lot of thumbs up
I do see thumbs downs but like I said
a lot of people the only beef is the
beef it's like don't trust smart don't
trust Middleton
and I'm seeing a lot of people talking
not a lot of people I'm saying a couple
things about Bobby Portis I'm not sure
if Bobby Portis is the play but what's
the play that you're looking for who
that be Mac yeah let us know it's very
easy to say no to Smart Middleton it's a
little bit harder to give a suggestion I
see Lori marketing
team man
we keep telling them it's not a hard ask
somebody saying Middleton Middleton for
Bobby let's just go check out Bobby
Porter all right since we're talking
about it what are his points talking
about it
people will send uh let's swap these two
wow can't even do Bobby is he not even
on there hey you guys know you guys know
who I just saw go back down uh Brian yes
sir Jonathan kaminga
interesting sneaky sneaky leg what is
that nine and a half
trying to make a minka's been bawling
guys he has been balling I I know we we
have Vibes about this uh
this is parlay I don't hate it I think
it's a play I also want to remind people
that Dante divincenzo has a narrative
play tonight all he needs to do is make
two threes he did play for he did play
on the other side before so that's
something I'm playing separately so just
just wanted to throw that out there
because I love a good narrative I was
also going to bring up
I love a good Grayson Allen that's a
thank you
hey in all honesty MB I like Dante
divincenza or Dante de Vegito better
than Chris Middleton
really
six points
it just depends on how much burn he gets
that's really it he's gonna play
no wigs
he's gonna play
m m brown Anderson said who's guarding
Middleton on the Warriors Middleton for
15.
Mike S 818 says thumbs up on kaminga
yeah is a really good pick I'm telling
you guys kamiga he's sitting at 10
points he's been over that in his last
three games that's a really good pick
but you you have a point with this Dante
demon chinzo pick like I six points
against his former team it's two triples
if we add it do we want to take out
Giannis
no we're locking in Giannis Giannis is
definitely getting 25. so are we taking
out Chris or are we taking out
smart or reefs
no Reeves is locked Reeves Reeves Gotta
Stay Reeves gotta stay all right I think
Middleton is Up For Debate in my opinion
let's try and let's try and swap out
Middleton and see what we get
better runs better odds
could be the this could be the deciding
factor right here
we went from five and a half to one to
almost six or over six and a half to one
so read it back out let's see what kind
of Vibes we get thumbs up or thumbs down
all right here we go Jaylen brown two
plus threes Austin Reeves over eight and
a half points Marcus Smart ten plus
points Giannis 25 plus points and Dante
divincenzo the Italian Stallion over
five and a half points
I like it man plus 659 plus 659 so if we
were to do the promo it is 25 you can
walk away with 164.
wait Ryan yes sir
yes go put in Commander
oh
instead of demon chinzo
[Laughter]
Brothers just see what it is
you know it's going to be higher yeah
this is what it is
before you do it we are getting thumbs
up from the audience yeah this is pretty
unanimous this is pretty good clean 15
dropped a money bag instead of the
thumbs up and see me three thumbs up
this looks good boys yeah I like the
divincenzo where Greg how about this
let's lock in this five-legger this is
valid and then let's go back personally
and toss two more legs in and really
Cash Out how's that nah yeah we could we
could we could lock it in but but all I
gotta say
so when kamiga get his 10 points and if
diving and if Dante doesn't
get his six
Ryan I told you so I'm just not on
record I'm just putting that on record
I think we lock it in boys
what are we talking about Craig this is
a this is the People's Party this is not
my parlay
people's parlay yeah you did remind him
earlier also
this came full circle first I could have
easily come into this show and reminded
everyone look at the comments right now
look at them saying yes to comminga guys
one of them says yes to come oh two of
them two of them two
Jay hatterman says AR thumbs down so
which one are we taking out then Greg
that's another one that's another one
that's another person that says yes to
come back I'm just saying Max Pfeiffer
saying divincenzo's better this is what
I love this this is so great I love it
but also there's
we have no consensus ever
hey no this is hilarious I honestly
think both of them is going to hit
dimincenzo and kamingo so like let's
just make it a six leg parlay who's
gonna tell us we can't can we can we
should we Brian aren't you about beat
right I thought you were about getting
rich no I'm about getting rich but this
is this is when we get in trouble this
is when we add a six leg and then the
six leg doesn't hit what if it hits
though then we all look like Geniuses
I'm not afraid of greatness I'm adding a
leg why not okay what are we are we
adding kaminga then
are we adding kaminga yeah that's what
it looks like they want us to act Amiga
CC loso says plus 1008 with Kanika I'm
with the money they want it they want it
they want to run Zippy said let's get
rich six leg that John we have to now
laughs
this smells like disaster
we're breaking rules here a little
forget a five-letter we're going six
legs plus 1400 Let's Get Rich wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait since we're at
plus 1400 real quick can we buy down
Jalen Brown from two plus to one plus
since we're already at let's do it let's
go let's be smart about it let's be
smart guys I mean it's not it's about
smart and I get carried away yeah yeah
my goodness we spent the last six
minutes getting carried away
and I get carried away guys
this is funny
Marcus I mean uh Jaylen there we go look
look at bams it's minus 2200 but it
keeps us still keeps us at plus 1100. I
like that well hey what's Mark is smart
go to Marcus Smart yeah we tease that
down yeah we tease that down as far as
we could because you can't do anything
less than 10 points
yeah yeah let's go to his assist
remember his assist was like super lucky
remember you're a smart man you're a
smart man
let's go let's go we're getting smart
about this now
yeah ah
H1 is good H1 is good eight to one is
good 25 to win 200. I don't I'm in I'm
all in I'm let's go
let's go that's how we think smarts work
smarter not harder guys all right guys I
actually love this now I love this read
it out all right so here we go here we
go here we go I'm excited about this
let's go uh Austin Reeves over eight and
a half points uh Jalen brown one plus
paid three Marcus Smart four plus
assists
giannis25 plus points Dante divincenzo
over five and a half points in a Revenge
game and Jonathan kaminga the Greg leg
as I like to call it over nine and a
half points
put that out so if it doesn't hit we
remember who's like it is the the people
but yeah I mean
they approved the people
Fresh Prince says he's gonna or Jay
hoderman says he's gonna hit three
Fresh Prince says we're going to be rich
Jack cam gave me the most amount of
Thumbs Up in a row I've ever seen this
is so lucky hey now I think we're vibing
hey The Vibes are good right now bye
Ryan all right right finish the milk
let's see what the odds are on FanDuel
let's see what the odds are oh no we
actually we see the odds plus 801 Ryan
one more time run through it and then
we're gonna go to we're gonna move on
all right
Austin reefs over eight and a half
points Jalen brown one plus made three
Marcus Smart four plus assists
Giannis 25 plus points Dante divincenzo
over five and a half points Jonathan
kaminga the Greg leg over nine and a
half points adds up six legs add up to
plus 801 25 to win 200. it's the TNT
promo if we lose if we somehow lose this
which I don't see how then we got our
money back
exactly get your money back
promo yeah put it in Click you're gonna
get it's a free bed it's free but you
get your money back please it's like
please saying he's putting gas in his
car tomorrow Max Pfeiffer I like it boys
javarius Collins we lit Lockheed hey
Ryan oh wow
The Vibes are high in the chat that's
how it's supposed to be that's that's
how it's supposed to be the visor
supposed to be high make sure you guys
tail us on FanDuel and you can now also
build parlays live during the game on
fanduels make sure you guys check out
that feature Ryan um let's grade some
bets let's grade some bets before we get
on up out of here uh do you see anything
in the chat that has caught your
attention uh well here's a little call
to action for you guys drop some locks
that you like tonight and uh and we'll
grade it uh The Vibes are just
Immaculate right now through the roof
right yeah I mean like what fresh prince
we're all gonna be rich uh this is just
this is beautiful Darian wants to know
who's driving the bus to the bank
that'll be me I'll come pick up I was
gonna say you're gonna be the bus driver
yeah I'll be the bus driver that's fine
uh exactly see closer said Giannis 30
plus we had that in the parlay how do
you guys feel about it
I like it I like it because that's it's
it's it's it's it's
coincides with the parlay so uh Fiona's
gets 30. we're hitting one leg of the
parlay I like it
close-up said shopping at Whole Foods
tomorrow Rayland Joyce said Christmas
gonna be good for my kiddos
let's go let's go all right uh hey let's
Get on Up out of here man it's time to
go get rich it's time to go get rich uh
for my for Greg ivory
actually Ryan hold up review the parlay
one more time please right there cool
yeah uh we gotta ask if we're posting
this anywhere follow BR betting on
social we will repost this but for now
our parlay Jalen brown one plus three uh
Austin Reeves over eight and a half
points Giannis 25 plus points Dante
divincenzo over five and a half points
Marcus Smart four plus assist and
Jonathan kaminga over nine and a half
points you add those six legs six legs
together and it adds up to plus 801 on
FanDuel
let's get it I'm feeling good about this
one Nevada is feeling good in the chat
Ryan oh my God wait
we got one more man
baller p2490 he's proposing to his wife
this weekend after we hit we love those
vibes love that love that love that this
if this when this hits and you propose
I'm gonna need a tag so we can post you
on social absolutely 100 in those videos
in those videos we love all those vibes
all the Good Vibes in the chat I'm
feeling it man I I think we're going to
win today I'm feeling it I'm gonna
manifest it uh we're good no more milk
mb's finished his milk my name is Greg
Ivy next to me is MB that's what I call
them you might know him as Michael
Boland and next to him is the man we
like to call on this show
producer Ryan uh till next time fellas
Let's Get Rich tonight peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]